ذهب يوم المقصورة اتفاقهم
أسترازينيكا تحب كل شيء يدق ستارمان
في بطولة Licra ciara Mines alpha
يبلغ في مدينة أو من أغسطس إلى
حجم كافيه بيزبه في داريل جونز
Biya المزعجة في مندي كان
القاطرة والجانيت التي قمنا بتطعيمها
هذا اللقاح في فرنسا وأوروبا
علينا الاستمرار في فعل ذلك لأن
أنه سيساعدنا على الخروج من الأزمة
ولكن على وجه الخصوص للرد على
المتغيرات نرى أن اللقاحات الأخرى
هي اليوم أكثر فعالية أو بالنسبة لي
ماتت هل ضحكت أو حتى تجمع فيفا
غارة على سولينيس فعل محطة المثورة
مارثا مالي ستارز ني يوربان
سوف الاتفاق astrazeneca المولود في إيان لا
تجديد خزانة الأدراج
بعد شهر يونيو سنرى
انظروا ماذا يحدث
الفتيات لكنها تجدف الدولة ستكون
ramalhète و atemi fifa في واحد
الداخلية في الموهبة بعد الصفقة
zeneca المدرجة التي تحدث لنا تصبح
كان من الصعب قراءتك
تلقيح من قبل السيد لا تشكل أي
مشكلة لا تقلق وإذا
أنت في صباح يوم غد من قبل آخر
لقاح أو ثوابت مثل الآخرين
مثل إضافة أرطال وجعل لا
مشكلة مع طبيعتنا لكرته
علق على الفرنسية yann m'vila ou
من عطاء حياة نتابري يا من هجوم
قال القراصنة السيدة كوينل أخيرًا
أمر